walk in to this video playing chess
nails just snails yeah you never know
this is that's very tough to see this is
albania albania this is just a very
small icon and i knew that at bay
albania is looking like that but tough
too tough to see okay let's think about
this can I do something something
different maybe g3 that's an interesting
sideline trying to transpose to the
kettle on here as like I play b5 very
interesting move blocking c4 he didn't
do that he just allows the normal
Catalan which is of course also
perfectly fine
yeah now black has a principal choice
taking on c4 the absolute main line or
the closest variation with c6 the early
c6 in fact is somewhat different 297
because of the exact line that we play
right now here why it has a very famous
trap if he now place night BTW 7 which
is totally normal there's night takes
his six winning a pawn okay him he knows
that all he avoided that i can i can
show you the line some in them in the
analysis afterwards this is really
aligned that that sometimes happens not
bt7 i got this in a tournament game in
fact very important game for for me that
i needed to win do score the the final
international master norm in 2011 in the
european club cap there is a video on
that on the channel quincy seven a
strange because i want to play Bishop f4
anyway and now i have threaten all kinds
of discoveries
okay yeah that's that's in fact now a
very comfortable situation there is some
c5 is a very good move for example
intending 94 to d6 yeah I come I died
what I try to play a bit quicker here
this is the move that that probably is
correct anyway so no use in in
pretending to it to do anything else
okay mmm Here I am night see form here I
might take on c5 if I go before even
that is good it's not totally convincing
really but even that is a pretty good
pretty good line I'd like to have a
night to to put on on d6 night see form
yeah this is this is good yeah 94 94
Bishop before takes 96 it's just good
for white with with this fork can I can
maybe take twice play rocket e 8j exam
it's probably also okay
interesting many tempting moves
taking on f6 is also not bad I need to
move and it is no use in burning all the
time and then get into time travel in an
excellent position ya know night c4 was
my idea as BC 96 looks very good yeah
come on let's do that not spend so much
time he takes 96 and this must be good
he needs to go into a discovery 237 or
queen bee 8 and cannot believe it not
sure that I'm winning or anything but it
looks very good there's also to consider
something like bc 596 Queen c7 and just
bc five yeah and he cannot take on be
too because would be one rupee seven SS
instantly winning also possible maybe
yeah this is the right way to go ok it's
playing a somewhat passive move I go
here I want a night on the six and not a
Bishop Bishop is nice but the night is
is the money in a way Bishop a six maybe
but I can take e seven and take f8 this
should be good
I should measure should have thought a
moment Bishop a success a bit a bit
irritating
that's at Bishop basics you must do that
that's the only move really Bishop
basics not sure what I do here he found
it taking on a six taking on c4 I am
that was that that actually should have
thought this thought of before hand
Bishop e7 Bishop which should be set
Bishop c4 Bishop f8 Bishop takes
everyone
hmm
that's not that's not that's not so
great really amazing
hmm they are not sure what what I should
do him and some some way there are some
ways to certainly keep some advantage
but what what's the best that's best way
to do that I'm not sure about at all I
take each seven takes e4 take fa to take
a one is there is there some way to
Bishop g7 Bishop g2 shop age six and not
sure something like that might work
Bishop e7 Bishop c4 Bishop f8 Bishop f1
Bishop takes g7 Bishop g2 and then
bishop age 6 threatening Queen g4 with
the maid the bishop on g2 can only
prevent that with bishop age of three
but this is really preventing it Queen
h5 there is Bishop f5 hmm ok I can also
take e seven Bishop c4 lookie one just
putting this Bishop 1d6 but does this
was really not what I wanted ok it's
them I can also play something like Luke
see one
it's not really really much much point
of that
it's there what about 95 is also not
going to much okay I need to move some
sometime useless Bishop see form with
also thinking to take the ship f1 Bishop
g7 Bishop g2 and then put it click Ouija
forward after that there is Bishop e3
and Bishop 83 and it's both our weight
after that I have Queen g5 with the
discovery
this might be very nice if it works but
i'm not sure if it is working Bishop f8
bishop f1 Bishop g7 Bishop g2 Quincy for
intending bishop f6 a bishop h6 with a
mate to come if he plays Bishop g2 or
Bishop h3 I go Queen g5 still
threatening that and I don't see I can
play Bush rh5 or something like that
that's not made very unfortunate
okay so what else is there i can take I
could try to play something like Queen
f3 here putting pressure on c6
okay if I can kenai river I could try to
sacrifice the exchange here Queen a free
bird s Bishop d5 that's the real problem
yeah spent ages here I didn't find a
real a real refutation of it yeah well
this this I could have played in like
two minutes it is it is slightly better
for white or maybe even some even more
but I hope for some direct way to to
play but it does not seem to be in
existence this is nice but not not
winning we are the main point is that
plug can get the bishop 2d fire which is
it's just a huge improvement over having
this cell on b7
yeah I want to get in some quick move
Sam maybe 97 Quincy form could be could
be an idea not sure why you played
Knight f6 just Bishop g5 looked very
normal and was slightly slightly better
yeah I'm not sure what you should do him
yeah does this the exact timing with the
c5 move was was a bit off getting this
that he got this special a6 and without
being being a directed punished really
was was very disappointing yeah and he
get this Bishop to g5 all the time now
and this is this is just the end of any
ambition to what to play for an edge
yeah Knight to Queen g-form let's let's
threaten something yeah 95 I probably
yeah I probably will take with the pawn
yeah now this attack here Queen g4 to
see form he always has Bishop d5 and
this is of course very important that
he's able to to to just keep the D file
close if I would be able to put in
rhukaan d6 for example this would be
very nice but hey just lets the the
bishop stay on d5 it's also the idea
between behind Luke c1 know what I'm
trying to do is maybe to take and then
after the sea pawn takes I push c6 or if
the opponent takes I maybe have cb6 and
some pressure on c6 so I'm increasing
the pressure on the c6 pawn
Thank You queen a6 could be an option
okay yeah okay well maybe wants to take
with with the rook which makes us some
sense of course came let's play the
strengthening move if I don't do that
something like cb6 is never really an
idea CA to hang so this is some just a
slight improvement like shouldn't be in
any any big danger anyway so now you can
put the rook on d5 yeah exactly okay
that's really tough really tough to get
anything going here yeah that's a very
active piece on d5 I need to I think I
need to exchange it really quickly take
care rook the one that it's just nothing
going on I have nowhere no edge
whatsoever here I will still try a bit
but there is no nothing substantial
Jeff okay let's see some some way here
to to do to do something very very tough
tough toe to find any idea ok Larry take
it looks it to a rocky to f4 king of
three but yeah it is just equal what can
you do
maybe I can get the King all the way to
your form
yeah it's just equal black an ambitious
idea for black would be g5 some some
more trying to isolate my e porn but I
think I can just push the king and it
does not does not lead to anything okay
so here and f4 maybe we will continue
this this game but it's obviously very
dry yeah maybe I can play f/4g for f5
but what exactly is this doing not much
is playing this somewhat somewhat slowly
though kg force maybe this check and g5
hmm
okay but I can just take this this check
ng5 is not really really dangerous yeah
I must be a bit bit cautious I'm trying
to still do something here which which
can be a really a mistake maybe it's it
would have been wiser to do absolutely
nothing but still like to continue it
but I can give this check out kinky 5y
mmm-hmm it's a bit risky what I'm doing
this one really going here ok anyway
I'll go at five this was the idea on a
long f5 through gave to Luc f7 the
general the general plan okay now we can
give this check here maybe I can play
King a for King g5 trying to do that as
mentioned all this is a slightly risky
check okay briefly rookie for is this is
this a move or is it totally stupid I
can have at least play rock d 2 ok so
over here black can give check now aged
six g6 check but at the end i can go
over to f6 try to win the sex porn
I think I'm threatening f6 now pawn to
f6 and this is I think something he
needs to address when i'm not sure if it
is a big threat but i think it is a
threat yeah at least we get some fight
going it is a bit risky but if you have
an equal end game with not much
happening if you don't do something
enterprising you're never going to win
just sitting and chatting and waiting
does not does not help let's get this g6
now
g6 make it also just take maybe yeah I
just take it if he takes on g4 I have f6
and if it takes on on f5 this is also
not particularly dangerous quickly if it
does not play g6 however i probably have
f6 oh wow really are looking for okay
form mm there's some alternative I am as
mentioned it is dangerous what I'm doing
here yeah but anyway what what else is
there look f-4e 6 look at five kingi for
EF is with the tempo unfortunately
hmm
hmm that's not that's not good not
really good
you
and why is he not taking there anything
else please check on I know I have for
you six always it just must he just
needs to take take e six takes rook
takes it maybe I've active enough to
draw this but I have my doubts yeah I've
i played this i just took to when your
risk them
no rook f2 is probably just just the
right move getting getting at the pawn
yeah this wasn't bad either I don't
really have a good malls yeah I know
passive but I didn't see a really good
one check
time warning check add 2 h 2 so that i
can take age 6 was bad
yeah I'm not not not sure if it would
have helped but Jeff
yeah I'm sorry I'm stupid and I need to
play rook h2 really i'm not really not
not clear if it helped ya but it's the
only absolutely only thing that I can
try check
white resign yeah just I mean what what
did game em you're winning out of the
opening basically and then I'm Chang
managing to that totally over present is
ending yeah I'm here why this is just
total [ __ ] at least I need to to play
the the the toughest moves with Luke age
too yeah I mean this kind of opening
players just atrocious really should
should be punished but here I took ages
but I didn't find find find a suitable
way to continue maybe really there yeah
I mean still should be some advantage
probably is but this is this is equal
this is equal yeah probably i must avoid
this this straight Jim should be
solution taking here maybe this is the
way I need to play
now this is all this is very good young
just winning the pawn the other side
didn't really consider I I considered
many many forcing variations like this
but he always has these kind of moves
especially Queen c7 that's just
unbelievable okay but this is what is
that maybe I have something and now c5
maybe this is better and it is in fact
very similar check or maybe it is better
to to time this differently and not play
this immediately something like before
someone something like that okay well I
here i have a variation that leading
that's leading to a very clear so is
this what i already showed you know the
way we played after you got this pawn
structure in it is just equal yeah I
should probably chat settle for a draw
simply I mean here I still tried things
which probably wasn't a good idea I can
I can play move let's say it before just
something like that is equal I wanted to
do something but probably this is a bad
idea yeah this is this is this is not
really on I had I had this idea but i
forgot that i didn't see that he can
play this rook f8 news i was always
hoping for this f6 ideas which is i mean
there is some danger
but it's nothing here there's something
nothing happening right yeah maybe maybe
just recapturing as is them earn the
tough I defense but it gets it gets
tricky you know yeah yeah I'm just lost
this is this I just pleasure is far too
ambitious leaders end game check so here
there is nothing channel thing to do ah
not good okay thanks for watching